all right so listen
um there have been a number of reports
with headlines like Donald Trump facing
136 years in prison
many such examples I am not going to
blow smoke
in anyone's body parts in my audience
Donald Trump is not in any real sense
facing 136 years in prison so let's talk
through this entire situation Donald
Trump is accused of 34 felonies and on
paper it is true that individually each
of those felonies could potentially
Garner four years in prison in some
insanely hypothetical sense we have
already seen a number of legal opinions
about this and these 34 felony counts
are all related more or less to the same
act or same scheme you might say and a
number of legal experts and remember
none of this is my opinion I'm just
going by what other legal experts have
said while in some extraordinarily vague
sense you could say Trump is facing 136
years in prison realistically the
maximum he would be facing for all of
these counts would be four and I believe
the real number will be zero now that's
just my opinion and we will get to that
in a moment let's start with an NPR
report called five things to know about
Donald Trump's felony charges what was
Trump charged with
the indictment unsealed includes 34
counts of falsifying business records
with intent to commit another crime and
Aid and conceal the commission thereof
these are class E felonies these are the
lowest classes of felonies in New York
in the state of New York each check
processed by the Trump organization
disguised as a monthly payment for Legal
Services under a retainer agreement is a
count is a count what do we know about
the catch and kill scheme this entire
scheme is based on the idea that Donald
Trump wanted to catch and kill by paying
stories that would be negative to his
reputation this involved a company
called the American Media Inc they
published The National Enquirer and
we've talked about different instances
of this there's this first instance
involving a doorman at Trump Tower the
doorman claimed to have a story about
Trump uh fathering a child outside of
marriage that was the first story The
Second Story involved Karen McDougall a
former Playboy Playmate Playboy Playmate
who said she had an affair with Trump
while Trump was married
Ami and their CEO David pecker were
involved with Donald Trump and Michael
Cohen in a scheme to pay for her silence
for a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and the third of three incidents may be
the most well known is the hundred and
thirty thousand dollar payment to adult
film actress Stormy Daniels to suppress
her allegations of unaffair trump has
denied all three of these stories the
article which we will link to in the
YouTube description for this clip talks
about what prosecutors need to prove how
Trump is reacting and what happens next
this is maybe the critical question the
judge Merchant set the next court date
as December 4th so already there will be
eight months until next court date
Trump's lawyers are asking for more time
which could already push this into
January or even spring of 2024. now
there's two sides to the delay tactic on
the one hand most many all attorneys in
criminal circumstances will often say
you want to delay as much as you can the
more you delay
the more you are potentially benefiting
yourself as the defendant for a number
of different reasons Witnesses could
forget
or they could die or they could refuse
to be involved or whatever the longer
you wait the weaker the case might
become for the prosecution due to things
that happen with Witnesses evidence
evidence could be lost misplaced tainted
whatever the case may be now there's
always a back there's always a rebuttal
to all of these well it doesn't matter
if the witnesses forget because they've
been deposed and all you have to do is
put up the deposition or uh of evidence
in this particular case is not going to
degrade the way it would in certain
types of violent crimes okay fine but
these are generally the reasons why
attorneys say it's often good to delay
uh prosecutorial priorities could shift
there could be a change in the political
orientation of a prosecutor's office and
you might end up seeing cases dropped or
whatever the case may be so as a general
rule
you often will hear defense attorneys
say you want to delay as much as
possible delay years if you can
the CounterPoint in this particular case
is that from what I've read Trump will
be required to appear in New York for
each stage of this and you could end up
in a situation where this trial or these
proceedings let's say because it may not
go to trial could start to interfere in
the day-to-day of Trump trying to
campaign for president
and if that is the case one could argue
it's actually not great for Trump to
delay until spring of 2024 that's when
he will be locked into a primary battle
and wanting to do rallies and there will
be elections and all these sorts of
things okay so that's where we are now
why do I think Trump will serve no
prison time well I just uh if if again
this is just an opinion people can
disagree with this okay
if you
think that at the tail end of a year or
more of delays
Trump won't take a plea he says he won't
that this will go to trial
that Trump will be found guilty and that
he will be sentenced at what then might
be 77 or 78 or 79 years old depending on
how long this all takes if you think
he's going to be sentenced to prison
then
I think all of that is unlikely but even
if he were I believe that he will be
allowed to serve whatever sentence there
is in home confinement now a couple
people wrote in and said no there are
special facilities for people you know
known like Trump or what
it's just my opinion guys I don't think
Trump will do a single day
as far as this case is concerned what's
coming up of course is Will trump be
charged in Georgia in Fulton County
where the charges would be more serious
and on and on all right so we're going
to follow that let's now go to Trump's
lawyers post arrest press conference
as many of my viewers and listeners of
course know I have many family members
who work in the field of mental health
and I think one of the most important
things that we can do is to both
increase access and reduce stigma when
it comes to Mental Health Services and
that's why I am thrilled that one of our
sponsors today is better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it is 100 online with better
help you can tap into a network of over
25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists an important word therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues you answer a few questions about
your needs and your preferences and
better help will match you with a
therapist that meets your needs you can
then talk to your therapist however you
feel comfortable could be text could be
chat phone video call you can message
your therapist anytime you can schedule
live sessions when it's convenient and
if your therapist isn't the right fit
for any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below